we are here to talk about the lemon
Escape
um it is an interactive program
sculpture by myself and Ann Johnson I'm
Charles Comstock
um and we have on the right a picture of
it from last year uh stranger 2022.
um the upper section is the actual
physical sculpture of the lights and the
lower section is the kiosk which is
running off of a Raspberry Pi 400.
um okay so we're going to talk we're
going to do a little
discussion about the concept of uh how
we can see to this the piece then we're
going to talk about some components of
the sculpture and some of the software
architecture that goes into it then
we're going to talk about how to program
patterns for the sculpture then we're
going to talk a little bit about musical
input through MIDI
um and and how that is now a new
external input that you can
provide to to adjust the patterns that
show up on the sculpture this year
um then we're gonna give some concluding
thoughts and onward onward to questions
and answers and hopefully hopefully
you've got some time for for that as
well so
all right backgrounds sure yeah so
um for myself I am an electrical
engineer and trained in the state of
Missouri and I graduated with my
bachelor's in electrical engineering
last year in May
um I work full-time as a lion designer
for an engineering firm in St Louis and
in my free time I create light-based
artworks I work in LED and neon very
often
um and I actually returned to school to
study electrical engineering after
many years tinkering with electronics in
my attempts to create sculptures so I
have a lot of love for makers DIY
diy-ers and luminant objects in general
this video that's on the slide is a most
recent piece of mine and here you can
see some of my trademarks which are
combining neon LED matrices a lot of
different Light Elements and then also
working with some Sign Making techniques
so
um I'm Charles Comstock my background is
in computer science I worked as a
software engineer for many years and
then I have been dabbling more in some
standard of digital art
playing around with what weird things I
can get deep on Jess and quill and
closure scripts and various things so
I'll put together pretty pictures on the
screen um I also did some Photography in
the past
um and uh that's
that's kind of
snapshot images versus uh building up
images is kind of a transition that I've
been taking my art through so
um
the concept of this sign came about
um as a way of
uh activating the logo of the stranger
conference and uh really just exploring
different ways that we could
collaboratively iterate together on an
art piece
um with my background in art I had
discussed with Bridget some of the art
that I do and it just sort of arose
naturally from that that they wanted us
to give us give this a shot I reached
out to Charles to get involved because
he has a really much deeper depth of
understanding of programming and has a
lot more experience with that and
together we've been able to really build
this like robust experience that people
can interact with
um so that was last year we brought the
the sculpture and had the interactive
code portals and then this year we did
want to add another interface for
interaction and I was drawn to using
midi specifically through my other
experiences and doing interactive media
installations midi really is this
universal language despite being
invented over 30 years ago
um is still ubiquitous and uh that sort
of longevity I think is really
impressive and also really opens up the
sculpture for a lot of different types
of interaction so we decided to go with
midi so we could have a live control
element rather than relying only on
loop-based programming just as a
scientific we took it to Arctica which
is a local Festival here um last fall
and like so where's strangely like it's
wonderful for folks with code background
because they they can explore it through
that right like it was really apparent
that also having a tactile component
really added to the piece by by opening
up the doors to both those that can code
and also those that can are interested
in music and and other forms of
expression so
oh
um the other thing I like
you know we set it up to be the shape of
the strange Loop program but I also like
this perfume it's like a really fancy
graphing calculator like that's that's
the best framing of this device like
beautiful glowy graphing calculator yes
oh and the name the name comes from yeah
the landscape which is the the actual
equation that represents the The
Stranger logo and the infinity sign and
um yeah there's there's a couple other
lemon skates but this is this is the one
that was closest matching for the logo
so
all right so some discussion on the
system architecture so the person that
attends the conference or comes up to
the sculpture that's user they can
interact with the midi instruments that
are besides the the kiosk so the kiosk
is a little computer below the below the
sculpture
um the kiosk just runs a browser
uh the
the user can upload new program you know
write programs in that kiosk or
separately if they run they use the
kiosk on online but if they're at the at
the sculpture then they use it through
the kiosks there and when they push keys
on the mini instrument then it pushes
that pushes those events forward through
the browser using the web maybe protocol
and sends those realizes on to the
microcontroller firmware the
microcontroller is responsible for
rendering every single frame of
Animation so it converts the webassembly
that is generated by the compiler in
Google browser kiosk it converts it into
actual pixel values and shoves that over
the sculpture LEDs when we receive midi
inputs then those come across as just
events and then the microcontroller
receives those events and updates places
in memory corresponding to the value
sent over by the events and then that
updates the next spring for animation
so
um this is kind of rough but like it
gives you a rough flow of how
information propagates through the
system
so
um so the browser kiosk this is this is
the same application that's hosted on
GitHub the link there is on the right uh
lower low right
um so it is an integrated development
environment
that we designed for the sculpture
uh it's written in cluster script it
contains a whole host of different
features but a fundamentally
fundamentally what it does is it takes
this little Vector programming language
that we designed and converts it into
webassembly and then the bytecode and
then if once you're actually attached to
the sculpture then you can upload those
bytecode outputs to the sculpture and
and render the animation that you wrote
in the browser on the actual sculpture
itself we also relay all the midi events
as I was discussing in the last slide
um
uh and and critically so when when
you're at the sculpture this website is
actually hosted on the Wi-Fi of the
sculpture versus when
you go to the GitHub version then that's
that's the same application it's just
hosted on GitHub so you can use it
wherever you want but it's not backed by
any back-end server versus when you're
actually at the sculpture then it's
backed by the the firmware on the on the
midi uh sorry
microcontroller
so
so basically you have to be on the
sculpture's Wi-Fi to upload to it yes
yes yes
so and that that's these extra little
features that are not visible on on the
GitHub version you can see there's a
send to sculpture as and that allows you
to name your piece on the sculpture and
that'll enter into the rotation like it
immediately transition and schedule that
new piece on the sculpture and then
once it's been uploaded then it enters
the rotation so periodically I think
it's at the conference will set it back
to like every minute or every two
minutes It'll reschedule any of the
existing sketches that people have
uploaded so
um
the the actual browser kiosk is running
I think I mentioned this before he's
been running on a Raspberry Pi 400 it's
a little single board version of the
Raspberry Pi except it has a keyboard
um so it's
I don't know I I originally learned a
program on a Commodore 128 and 64 and
it's kind of the same form factor so
it's a it's a nice throwback to that so
um but the main thing about this page is
it's simulating what will happen on the
sculpture
um so you can use it to create your
patterns
so
I'm going to talk about the microcontrol
a little bit so microcontroller that's
running all this it's in the esp32 uh
that's uh it's a little dual core 240
megahertz microcontroller uh 320 KB of
Ram four Megs of Flash
it's got integrated Wi-Fi and Bluetooth
they're they're cheap they're like seven
dollars a pop like you can throw them
into any little project that you want
but they're they're really pretty cool
um
so also I I can't think of the use case
of the temperature range is something
like negative 40 to 110 or 105 Celsius I
think so I I don't think you could put
in space because of a radiation but
they're they're still pretty cool so um
it hosts the actual web application uh
and then it also runs a webassembly
interpreter called wasn't three so it
takes the by code that we uploaded from
the web page and runs that to generate
each frame of Animation
um as mentioned before those programs
are also stored in the flash memory on
the device so we can schedule them again
and then it also
retransmits the the mini messages and
updates the memory map for the
webassembly interpreter
So Physical sculpture I'm going to talk
a little bit about the physical
sculpture itself this was created to
break apart easily and so come come
together and break apart
as close to painlessly as possible to
make that easy for transportation
um we decided on this specific size for
the sculpture because it is the way to
maximize the five meter long pixel
strips that make up the loops on the
inside
um so like I said I've been working a
little bit in Sign Making techniques and
I drew from that inspiration to come up
with this form for this for the
sculpture it's made out of frosted
acrylic on the front and a the body is
made out of aluminum
um it has a plywood CNC backing and uh
just breaks apart comes together at the
seam in the middle so
um
okay so let's take a look at how to
actually program new animation patterns
for the sculpture
so
the language that we're using to program
patterns is a vector programming
language so Vector programming languages
are a solution for for problems that
involve a fair amount of parallelism
examples being writing out all the
pixels on your display on your computer
[Music]
um
like early examples of vector language
is APL that's I think mid 70s or
something like that but the most common
place that you run into Vector languages
these days is in graphics card shaders
so you've got you know a giant 2D array
of all the pixels on your on your screen
and you farm out the rendering of every
single Pixel on the screen to a whole
host of shaders for our purposes we're
not actually paralyzing anything but we
are using that model
um and the fundamental model for Vector
languages that I think kind of
differentiates it from more imperative
or functional cell is it's would don't
call us we'll call you so Anna for our
particular Park chair like the pixel
color function is what the user is
entering in that little text box that we
showed on the kiosk page so that is the
function that you're defining and then
this Loop just happens invisibly like
you don't you don't see it but that's
that's what is being evaluated to
generate the pixel for every index of
the
sorry that is the expression that is
being evaluated for every index of the
vector so
um so
and and this allows us to do certain
tricks like we can do uh interlacing if
we want to increase the frame rate so we
don't necessarily need to call the
update on every single frame update we
can flip flop between frames
um
but
the user provides the pixel color
function and then the microcontroller
and the browser and everything else is
responsible for actually figuring out
how to render that
so this language that we used you know
it's Unique to this culture but it is uh
Loosely inspired by the the tixie
language which is time index X and Y
coordinates
um and I don't actually know who created
it like their website is just kind of
blank page but it's it's neat and it's
worth taking a look at um and was
definitely a big inspiration for the
language here
so some Basics on the language
can we want to calculate the color of
each pixel at index I we're given time T
so uh because as as we saw on the
previous slide this pixel color only
accepts that index and the time value
um so
for the square brackets what we're doing
is we're just emitting like a hue
saturation and luminance value for each
pixel we chose two saturation and limits
as the as the default output because
that allows you to do nice smooth color
transitions we'll talk a little bit more
about the the color modes in the coming
slides but under the hood this is still
being output as the underlying red green
and blue intensities that are being
output to every single
three prong LED on the actual sculpture
um you know because when you have a
color LED which you don't actually have
a value-free color you have a red pixel
led a green pixel LED and a blue pixel
LED and they're all just sitting right
next to each other on a tiny little
package and so
um that's that's literally the
intensities that we're we're putting out
and those are mixed together into a
color that is discernible to the eye at
a distance
um the language only supports for
external inputs Like We Only We support
time in milliseconds
um I think that's system time it's not
like times from the start of the sketch
but uh
and then what we've added this year is
we now support um some some midi events
and we'll get to that as we move forward
in the presentation
um
uh deeper dive onto the color modes
so the hsl is Hue saturation limits Hue
is your position around the color wheel
um so it's
you know zero to 360 degrees or in our
case we're mapping from zero to two by
five
um saturation value is the
sort of distance from Gray it's like how
pure the color is
um and and then actually when you think
about that in the underlying pixels
that's that's how much I've just read or
how much of just green or how much of
just blue versus if you want a grayscale
value then you have all those
intensities to be equal
um
and and illuminates the sort of like
you're on it's a dimmer switch it's your
your total emission of light you're
you're on off
um so
uh and then to proportional hsl is sort
of this this weird mode that we invented
to to make things look nice for the sign
which is that
and and I'm gonna there's a better graph
of this than I think the next slide but
um the the problem is is that each pixel
there's two Loops in the sign right like
this it's two lemon Scapes that are
offset by 0.1 meters
and so if you want to have the colors on
the inside and outside Loop match then
you need to remap your index not in
relation to the total number of pixels
available but just in terms of the
pixels on one particular Loop and then
you want to make sure those two values
are the same so that you get you know
red on the inside and red on the outside
of the same position
um
so
all right so
kind of closer to decide because there's
a there's a better slide showing this
later but we support for each pixel we
support the the site for each value of
the expression we export the x and y
coordinate of that particular pixel that
you want to evaluate the radius
represented as R and Theta or heading
which are the polar coordinates
um and then we expose the number of
constants like n being the number of
pixels L being the number of pixels in
one Loop that's for that proportionality
we were talking about
um or width and height and width and
height they're really useful if you want
to remap from having uh you know the
exact X location the Y location if you
want to have the proportion of how what
percentage from the left to the right
you are then you you would do like a
float x divided by width and then you
you know where you were in the space
um this will be a little clearer on the
next slide so this this little
coordinate slide kind of gives you an
idea where where everything is so we've
got our uh X and Y coordinates of 0 0
the origin is an upper left y descends
downward from there X goes from left to
right ascending
um
and uh we have the radial distance from
the center that's this this R component
and then we have the rotational position
around the center origin not the zero
zero origin but the actual center of the
sculpture that's what the the r and
Theta are in reference to uh and then
finally we have
the the index 0 which is the inner right
red Loop that's transitioning into
yellow and that continues on through
green and then transitions to blue and
then when I equals L that's the
discontinuity where we're jumping from
the the first Loop of the sculpture to
the second Loop of the sculpture and
then we continue along from Blue into
purple and then back to red and then we
arrive at I equals m which is the total
number of pixels which is 581.
um and the the program below
um this hsl flow divided by n times two
five five that's just remapping the
index to be proportional to the total
number of pixels
um if we didn't if we just put a float
of I then then red would Loop more than
once because
um you know we only map from zero to two
five five for for each color value so we
need to remap that into this reduced
space and then expand it back out to the
space available
um and we'll we'll see that again when
we actually look at the the control
interface
um okay so we expose a few functions
your basic arithmetic both for floating
point and integer uh we support some
limited automatic type coercion we also
support link
Force type casting between integer and
flow
um if if you've got a sketch for your
quantizing things too much like the the
values jump considerably often it's
useful to recast it into float so it'll
smoothly transition as opposed to kind
of jumping between each integer then we
also expose some basic math functions
like absolute value
ceiling floor rounding modulus you know
so that you can constrain it to a
certain thing and then loop back over
just uh exposed square and square root
um and we've got the trigonometry uh
functions sine cosine and changement and
then we have a couple conditionals the
language does not support
um like an if conditional but it does
support
um conditionals in the sense that you
can you can feed it a clamp function so
you say I want to make sure that the
value is between a lower and upper bound
and it falls below the lower bound and
we just want to give the lower bound it
falls above the upper bound then we want
to take that outbound for a step
function that's like if the threshold is
below the value then we do zero is above
and then one smooth step is similar to
this step except that we got a lower and
upper bound but we do a smoothing curve
so it's a continuous function instead of
a discontinuity of churning directly
from off to on and then next is a is
like a linear interpolation so that lets
you have an a value and a b value and
then some parameter T that's a position
in between and so if T is zero then you
will get a n of T is one then you'll get
D so you can combine a mix and a step to
kind of say all right when we're below a
threshold then we want T to be zero
which makes it be the value a and
there's actually compiler support in
there where to optimize it because uh
you know it evaluates all sides of the
tree but it okay
it doesn't need to evaluate both the A
and B in that step condition example so
there's some little optimizations that
it takes care to speed things up
um all this is documented on the kiosk
software and in a couple different
places there so all there's far more
details there and
me going over here is probably not the
the best use of the time but uh feel
free to approve that at a later date so
um all right some new features that
we've added this year is that we now
also support some variables in language
so the variables it's just a let
statement where the name of a variable
and then expression and then that gets
plugged into the color statement
afterwards
um
so in this particular example I'm
constructing two fake low frequency
oscillators at different rates and using
that to modulate the r and um a modulus
of the radius as well and then also
adding in a Time component and we'll
show this example on the sculpture in a
little bit um you can also add comments
um and yeah again there's there's
language reference all over the site um
that goes into much more depth than each
function is explained um care point so
um so let's let's see some some demos
so so this is this proportional example
where we have the red and the blue
mapping into the same locations
um we can easily adjust things so we use
let's say we want radial distance from
the center so we get this expansion
patterns
um if we want to smooth out that rate
and slow it over a
wider range then we can divide it and if
we want it sharper and to change more
often then we can multiply
um
if we want to slow down the whole
animation then we can divide by a larger
constant to buy Time by a larger
constant um and you know all this works
for the X and the y or
a heading
you know we've got these these color
sweeps as we we move around the space
um discontinuity where we transition
from 360 to zero
um the interface has some debugging
affordances so you can you can pause the
animation I'm going to switch it back
yeah also there's there's all these
examples I know I most of the way I
learned a program and most of when I
learned a new programming language as I
look at countless examples and so we do
in fact have countless examples for you
to peruse at your own Leisure
um
but you know for this color changed
example if we pause it we can jump
around in time and and see what it would
be of different T values
um and then we can
switch back to running
um this uh Center sculpture as again
this is only available when we're
connected to the sculpture which is this
is currently connected to it
um and that allows you to name a sketch
and send it to the sculpture
um I talked a couple of times I
mentioned the language guide there's
both language guide here and then most
of the content is also available under
the help
um though it's split out into you know
subsets and not like a huge information
dump uh but over here it's nice because
you can still see the animation and you
can still read the docs at the same time
but uh it's it's probably a little
easier to read Under The Help menu
um
so
uh
and then I'm not gonna dive too deep
into this webassembly section
um but we do have a full model of how
this is modeling what's actually
happening on the sculpture so this is
running on the right we're seeing the
memory map of a limited version of the
sculpture so just a 31 pixel version of
the sculpture
um and we're seeing that this initial
section is showing like the constants
that are baked into the webassembly
image this this is just literally the
memory of the web assembly uh binary we
can see the actual contents of the web
assembly binary over here that's not
very useful but it's it's there if you
want to
um
uh and so if you scan through the the
hex so play here you this this section I
think is where it's representing the X
and Y and R and Theta coordinates for
each pixel and then um there's a section
here that's empty that we'll we'll talk
about that's that's actually where the
amplitude is being stored
um which is how we're receiving key
information into the sculpture we'll
talk about that for for many and then
you know we have this nice little
matrix-esque view of these color values
being re-represented in the decoded
results
um and on the left we've got this uh
this is this various steps through the
compilation process so you can see where
it's doing type annotation and if
there's if there's some confusing value
you're like why is it you know mixing
these values in the the type conversion
doesn't work out you can you can
actually inspect and see how those are
applied
um
uh very happy to talk about that more
details that's not the focus here though
so uh back to the exhibit so let's let's
cut to the the actual screen for a
second so it's the lemon skate in the
background for a second and let's first
do color Chase example
yep so we've got color chasing happen or
we can do or is that that LFO example I
think is this one
so
you can send that over and now we'll get
these kind of little pulses and so the
fast pulses that we're getting I think
are from the lfob that's the the moduli
the modulation on the
radial distance module in Mod 32 versus
the LFO a which is running uh just a
little bit slower but that's that's sort
of your radial distance from the center
um so there's lots of different ways
that you can express yourself using the
constraints of this language and
it's uh
when purchasing what all you you can
create with it so all right okay so uh
you may be asking why specifically midi
and I did brush on this a little bit
um earlier by noting it's ubiquity but I
wanted to dive a little bit further into
that because it is why I chose this
specific
um protocol to incorporate in this I
think that midi is one of the first
examples of a truly open source
technology
um and for that reason it's interesting
and ties in with the purpose of this
conference
um in the 80s as musical synthesizers
were becoming to be manufactured as an
industry they were running into a lot of
issues with um
inter being able to be compatible with
each other because different synthesizer
manufacturers were using their own
standards and solving uh communication
issues their own way often synthesizers
were not able to communicate
and so the head of the Roland
Corporation saw that this was going to
be an issue within the industry and
decided that it would be in the best
interest of everyone in the industry if
they created a standard that everyone
could use so that that way everyone was
kind of speaking a Common Language so in
1981 he reached out to the oberheim uh
the head of the oberheim uh company it
was another synthesizer manufacturer who
had created a competing
data transfer protocol and started talks
about you know I think we should develop
a protocol that we all use in common so
a couple so strategically they decided
that they should create a protocol
that's inexpensive to implement so that
manufacturers wouldn't have to invest a
lot to enact it in their own products
and then they made it so that the
protocol itself would be free to use and
in that way by making inexpensive to
implement and free to use so no license
required the midi protocol became
standard throughout the music industry
and it's still everywhere today
um so I just thought that was a really
interesting piece of history and
probably had some lessons about why and
how certain open source Technologies
become successful and ubiquitous
um so the picture on the left here is a
five pin data cable so that is what a
midi uh data cable looks like nowadays
pretty much all instruments communicate
over midi to USB
um but our sculpture will accommodate
five pin midi cables if you have
instruments that only have those as
support we do have adapters
um and then we have some pictures of
very common
midi controllers so you can have
something like the Akai which is just a
really nice mappable control board to a
something like the arturia there which
is again gives you a lot of different
controls that can be mapped to anything
you also see a lot of mini drum machines
and sequencers
so next slide
so as far as how the midi protocol Works
um whenever a midi event happens a
packet is sent and these packets contain
information
uh pertaining to what the message is
um and then the data contained within
the message so
for control change messages
um in a menu system you're going to have
128 controls and each of those controls
can be matched to zero to 127 so 128
different steps of value so often you
see this as a knob a slider or a touch
strip so those usually have a resolution
of 128.
um
we for our sculpture even though for a
typical MIDI controller you would have
zero to 127 control change channels we
were remapping everything to four ports
so zero to three
um an example of one control change type
of message would be the pitch Bend so
that's a special type of midi message
where you're able to take a a note
that's already on and then kind of
vibrato up and down
um to a resolution of over eight
thousand up and down either way
um so I've been working a little bit on
the controller that takes advantage of
this in a creative way and hopefully
I'll have that to show off
um but the the Workhorse midi messages
that I've been working with have been
the no on and no off messages
so you basically specify this is a note
on message you give it the no and then
you specify the velocity of the note
which is the protocol's way of trying to
translate how hard a musician is playing
something so like
um I get something that to me makes
maybe really interesting is it's an
attempt to translate a live performance
into a digital representation so uh
thinking about velocity that would be
like how hard are you pressing this
piano key so
with a note on message you can specify
again the note that the notes on what
note it is and then how hard it's being
played
um so cool all right so let's uh take a
look at how some of those work on this
culture I'm not brief like there's a lot
of code on this slide we're going to
look at the exact examples on the
sculpture in a second but I just wanted
to reorder it so you know we we've
remapped to Ports zero to three just so
that
um you know we're trying to accept any
midi instrument being plugged in and so
we don't want to have to figure out you
know what what things all about on a
particular device we just want to remap
them all into this small subset so that
any knobs or dials that you have on your
device will will be applicable yeah so
um so we're going to show the control
example then we're going to show a
picture example we're going to we're
going to adjust the heading so the color
is going to swipe based on the pitch
then we're going to do an amplitude
example
um so amplitude is something that we we
kind of developed we wanted to allow the
sculpture to represent
um the effect of pressing down the chord
so pressing down multiple keys
um and so in in sound that's that's you
know for your transforms and various
coefficients and and difficult uh to to
represent uh easily in particular it's
like it's like a lot of continuous
values
um so in order to sort of drop that into
something that we could use on the
sculpture what we do is when you hit a
note
um you have a velocity and that velocity
is from zero to 127 so we double that
and we set that in an amplitude array
and we drop that into the memory map of
the web assembly and so and then we do
like a windowed five uh that sorry
a gaussian convolution of width 5 over
the particular values at each position
so that's that's like an averaging or a
window operation that that Smooths and
allows hitting a node at a specific
location to Blossom over the surrounding
area so it's not
it's not actually What notes or values
would do on an on a real instrument
exactly but it allows you to get that
same expression of hitting a chord and
having an effective sculpture in an
interesting way
um we do also support as input the last
note and last pilate last velocity
function and that's just purely the the
exact note value from 0 to 127 that you
last pressed and the last velocity of
that press if you if you press several
notes and then you release one of them
it will revert back to the note and
velocity of the previous but it's it it
the sketches that use that will jump
around a lot and we'll see that in a
second so let's take a look at the
sculpture again so let's look at the
where is this
yeah
so this is an example using the control
values
so if we look at the actual sculpture
when I slide these we're modular we're
adjusting the X offset so we're moving
the the section that is red
because that's in the red component of
the the output
then I'm going to adjust the second
slider and we're getting y component and
this is this is like I'm adjusting a
slider on the external device
um but you can also do that in the web
interface
um
and and then finally that this is
adjusting the amount of blue as a as
related to the radial distance from the
center
so
um so that's that's an example using the
control values again we're just using
zero one two one and two here we do
offer three that's not used by that
sketch
um
but it is available
um let's take a look at an example using
amplitude
so this one is actually using both
amplitude and the slider so if I press a
key on the keyboard then we will see
blossoming in a corresponding region on
the on the sculpture and then if I
adjust the slider then you can swipe
that color and move it across it
um you know if I hit if I hit two keys
then we'll see multiple regions Blossom
um and this this graph down below that
is that is the amplitude graph that is
being reprojected onto the screen uh
sorry yeah I don't know if that's
visible but that's on the that's on
um the presentation section but not on
on the actual sculpture
um so yeah that's that's that's this
amplitude effect where we get this these
nice blossoming colors at various
locations on the sculpturing and again
because because we have this little
programming language that you can map
that however you want you can you can
readjust how that amplitude affects the
particular sketch that you're making so
it's a it's a nice new uh input
um uh and then let's do
orientation oh no there's a there's a
simpler version uh there is a kitchen
heading yeah so this is the example that
was on the slide so this this example
I'm now going to adjust the pitch and so
we're getting color swipes as we as we
move as I move my fiction finger up and
down the pitch slider
um let um likewise if I if I move to a
slider then then it has the same effect
um so
um
and then let's go to the last note
example
and this this one is a little more jumpy
as
there we go uh this is a little more
jumpy so depending on how hard you hit
you do adjust both the color and here
I'm going to softly hit it so we don't
we only impact the center versus if I
hit it hard then it's impacting further
out
um this one the last note and last
velocity is a little harder to to map
into something interesting but it's a
good challenge so and all this is also
working with the keyboard below so you
don't need to have a midi instrument
attached you can you can use this
internet interface to test it
um
so
oh uh and
it's going to hook in a second about
making your own midi devices but we do
support
um some debugging assistants there
without which is that we log all the
messages coming in so when I press
um Keys then we can see these note on
and note off messages and then the
channel they're coming in on the
velocity and and I'm sorry the note and
then the velocity and likewise for
control values which will just you know
flood the console with output but all
that's available if you if you toggle
this little button so
I wanted to as part of my uh
participation this year encourage
everyone to be to the conference to take
this as an opportunity to build your own
midi instrument dust off your Arduino
get it fired up try to try to write a
sketch where you're outputting a midi
message
um bring it to the conference and we'll
hook it into the sculpture and see what
happens
um so I am working on a midi controller
myself I'm using an Arduino Leonardo and
I'm using a really well supported
library from the Arduino Group which is
at the link provided there
midi usb.h
um so it's really simple to work with
um I included this example function of a
note on message and even just reading
through here I'm sure you can see where
you can switch out these variables of
Channel pitch and velocity and
really open up a lot of opportunities so
I have here this very simple pressure
sensor uh sketch that I've been working
on
um and this year the monitor is
outputting the readings from a variable
pressure sensor so as pressure increases
the resistance changes and in this
serial monitor you can see a really
simple sketch that I've written
um where it is sending many notes on or
off based on the reading so hopefully
that opens up some ideas there's a lot
you can do really
um and as we can see here on the log
page
you can go into here and see that we've
got it's recognizing this midi uh
Arduino Leonardo input
now as a note if you're debugging with
this for it to log to the console you do
have to come to the editor and check
this before it will start
um reading so just make sure you do that
and as you can see here here here's some
of it popping up
but again hopefully that opens up some
ideas and get some flow I'm also working
on something with an accelerometer that
I'm holding another so that's my
challenge to everyone who might want to
get into the hardware tinkering space
um again this was just a really uh
simple breakdown of a Mini pack it kind
of included for anyone who's trying to
dig into it themselves so I'll let you
guys work through this if you're taking
on the challenge of building a midi
controller
so I wanted to talk just briefly about
design constraints and how that can help
you build interesting things
um so this shows up in art space that
shows up in engineering Solutions
like if you have interface boundaries
and have design constraints and that
that like forces the shape of your
solution into a particular space and
that is critical to find a solution like
if you don't have those constraints you
can't find a solution so some examples
in this project where that that shut up
like why are the dimensions of the
sculpture 2.1 meters by 0.8 meters well
that matches the Arc Length of those
five minute LED strips so if if we want
to have a larger sculpture we would need
a longer than five meter LED strips
um
you know why do we choose webassembly
well because webassembly is an
established standard so we could easily
use an existing
um version of The Interpreter on the
microcontroller and then of course
browsers all have that built in and so
you know we could debug and take a look
at what it worked in the browser and I
had confidence when we were moving the
code that worked in the browser and
transitioned to the micro controller it
was it was I knew that it would work
ahead of time unless there was some
problem with the particular interpreter
there on the micro controller because it
was matching the standard
um so and it's it's so invaluable to
have like two reference versions of
something where you can you can compare
the two and make sure that you
understand both are working because you
can iterate fast on one and then you get
verification on the other
um and then you know we've talked a
couple times about why midi input is
amazing but you know it gives us
interactivity through code and tactile
and um you know
heavily documented yeah very important
yeah very heavily documented I mean I've
got two instruments sitting in the room
that support it and I don't know if
you're a little okay minis in in your
bag but you know the countless little
instruments that you can use
um and and they all output
the same protocol and so you're
constrained to that protocol and because
we accept the web media API then we can
accept that input so you know bring
bring in whatever instrument you have
that are interested to say like in
particular if anybody has like a like a
drum sequence some type of sequencer or
a drum machine where you can kind of
program using the interface that then
outputs midi then you could have a
sketch that is taking input from a drum
machine and then turn into output on the
sculpture
um and so that that constraint of using
established protocol allows us to to
just keep the problem within the space
but also expand what you can do yeah
really quick conclusion
bring your own patterns create your own
patterns
please try building your own Community
instrument or bring any novel midi
instruments that you have
um and have fun and experiment like
again I brought up earlier about
examples and looking over coding
examples like a beautiful thing of how I
went home program on the Commodore was
you could just like flip it on and off
if it was broken so with this browser
based little interface like you can't
you can't break the interface in the
browser like worst case you just reload
the page but like it's trivial to
experiment with so don't be afraid to
try the IDE is very nice the virtualized
sculpture I think will really help a lot
I know it's helped me a lot as I've been
working through building building
controllers so so have have fun uh and
we wanted to put in some acknowledgments
uh thank you strange Loop thank you Alex
Miller in particular as well for uh
giving us this opportunity and
supporting us through this um thank you
to Arch Reactor which was the Makerspace
where the form of the sculpture took
shape
please visit the lemon Escape pageant
yeah that's right a lot of skatepage but
also go visit the chat room we'll be
answering questions there and and if
there's questions and you know if
there's if there's things that would
assist uh we are happy to add that as
well so
I know I'll probably be posting progress
as I'm working on what I'm working on
over the next week